on peut comprendre la légitime tristesse
et colère de la famille qui a perdu un
membre de sa famille compris euh un
jeune adolescent 17 ans après il faut
pas que ça soit prétexte à toutes les
violences dans la société dans laquelle
on vit qui est quand même assez tendu
rien ne serait justifié la violence et
je pense que chacun doit revenir à la
raison puisque aujourd'hui les émeutiers
les violences les pillages les
agressions les incendies de bâtiments
publics ne seraient en rien lié à la
cause pour ce jeune homme je pense que
quand on mène une cause noble descente
en respect vis-à-vis de la mort de ce
jeune homme elle doit être respectueuse
de nos règles de nos lois et notre État
de droit et c'est très inquiétant
puisque on a l'impression désormais que
la justice se fait dans la rue ne se
fait plus dans les tribunaux on veut
bien reconnaître que l'émotion suscité
par le décès d'un jeune homme de 17 ans
et légitime sauf qu'on a l'impression
que en fait il y a les morts qui
comptent et puis il est mort qui compte
pas j'ai pas souvenir que pour Éric
Moreau se policier au moins qui a été
tué suite à refus d'obtempérer ou même
Mélanie Lemay c'est gendarme tué à
Pont-Sainte-Marie par un refus
d'obtempérer aussi j'ai pas l'impression
que des acteurs de cinéma que des
chanteurs ou que des footballeurs cm ce
soit ému et qu'ils aient mal à leur
France en voyant ça et j'ai pas
l'impression que l'Assemblée nationale
est féminine de silence pour ses
policiers ou ces gendarmes
systématiquement elle l'a fait pour les
victimes du terrorisme tant bien que ce
peu et heureusement mais malheureusement
on a l'impression que quand un policier
meurt c'est normal et quand une autre
victime il y a toujours un drame lorsque
quelqu'un meurt il y a pas pour moi des
hiérarchies entre les décès sauf que
c'est pas le ressenti des policiers qui
estiment qu'il y a deux points de mesure
[Musique]